the other thing i want to talk about is
how many bitcoiners are up on their
investment we saw a chart earlier that
shows about 75
of bitcoiners are still up on their
investment right so if you look at uh
yeah so this was from uh i'm not even
gonna try to pronounce the last name but
vignesh put up a article the other day
that said despite bear market 75 of
bitcoin wallet holders are in the green
still so if we pull up the chart you can
see here that 70 to 75 percent are still
within their their money and i saw
another one from dylan the other day i
believe that if you had bought at the
all-time high of bitcoin's price 69 000
or whatever it ended up being and you
dollar cost average every single day
since you just bought the exact same
amount every single day since that you
would still be up on your investment
because of how much we we've
transitioned since then so ultimately
again for the retail base what we've
seen is that that is the best way to uh
get involved in the asset to start
acquiring the asset is just to not
necessarily time the market but just be
in the market whether it's every day
every week every month whatever just set
yourself up on a regular schedule and
that way you don't have to worry about
the constant fluctuations you don't have
to try to time the market you don't have
to miss out on other opportunities
because ultimately if you miss uh the
the the best days in the market we've
seen this with the stock market for sure
you miss out on a ton of price
appreciation so it's much more
beneficial usually typically to the
regular investor if you just buy the
asset on a regular basis versus just
trying to time the market we have
another chart here that looks at the
long short term holder supply in profit
and loss so if you look at 2018 2019 and
then you zoom out and you look at back
at today the profit and loss of
long-term holders is 67 compared to 13
right so uh you can see the supply held
is is all the way down at 13 versus the
bull in the bear markets that we've seen
on this chart and these things are all
interesting because we talk about this
all the time and again will and dylan
that you guys know them they come on the
show and they show us these charts
and to me it's just incredible what we
can see from a
uh an on-chain metric perspective right
this is unlike any other financial asset
in the world where you can literally see
in real time who's holding what how are
they holding it how long have they hold
it how has it moved how is it
transitioned are they up on their
investment are they down on their
investment a lot of the other stuff is
kind of uh mind games to a degree where
you have to dig through data and you
have to parse through things and make an
educated guess we can literally see four
fact here 24 7 transparent market
exactly what is happening and again
maybe for most retail users or most
retail investors this doesn't matter you
just believe in bitcoin you believe in
the asset you believe in the
fundamentals and you're just gonna
continue to acquire it through dollar
cost averaging daily monthly yearly
whatever it is but ultimately what we've
seen is that these metrics are extremely
helpful not only for traders but average
people also to that point where you're
able to tell exactly what's going on
with bitcoin what do you think about
what we've seen with the the percentage
of people in profit john yeah that first
chart it's interesting because it seems
like every single bear cycle we set like
a new minimum right or at least a new
minimum for people that are a percent of
people that are in profit so it went
from 30 to 42 then 40 45 to 50 percent
then 51 to 60 and now we're sitting at
70 to 75 percent of people that have
held bitcoin over the long term are in
profit and that's because that for price
every time we have that bull market it
seems like we're setting a new floor
price when we have that draw down um and
look people that are dollar cost
averaging are wreaking the benefits of
this right they have continuously bought
all the way up all the way down all the
way back up all the way back down all
the way back up um and it's working out
well for them right 75 of them are in
profit and bitcoin has only been above
this for 300 days right or for three to
four hundred days so when you think
about that in the lifespan of bitcoin
over 12 years it's keep dollar cost
averaging you will be in profit excuse
me not financial advice so don't even
claim that i said you will be but people
have historically clearly been in profit
if they have dollar cost average into
bitcoin over the last call 12 years five
years um
whatever metric you want to use looking
at this chart i someone commented in the
chat and they said uh dca hourly on
strike not financial advice uh and it's
funny i don't know i can't tell who that
is from their their name but someone
told us that they do that at the at the
brunch they said uh one of my easiest
ways this is them talking they said one
of their easiest ways to convince people
to buy bitcoin right all their friends
they're obviously i feel like most
bitcoins get that reputation if your
friends aren't super interested in that
you're like oh you're the bitcoin guy
right yeah and uh
uh so he was like yeah i became that guy
and my easiest way to start convince
people was i told them about everything
related to that and then eventually uh
they just get tired of hearing about
that right and like we get it we get it
we get it maybe we like it maybe we
don't but then he started pulling out
his strike app and he's like look i
literally buy bitcoin every single hour
of the day
and they're like holy [ __ ]
right because you just see it you just
flick up the chart and you see he's
making purchases literally every single
hour on strike and just dollar cost
averaging would you rather do that or
dollar cost average like once a day so
if you have called 100
hey would you rather do 100 at 2 p.m or
noon every single day or would you
rather do you know throughout the day
called 10 for ten hours throughout the
day well i don't know exactly how it
works on strike i haven't done it myself
um but i think the general consensus
right is like the more often you can do
it is probably better because you remove
some of the time variable uh but at the
end of the day like you do it every week
every month whatever like people do it
with stocks it's direct deposit and
sometimes it does auto buy directional
though yeah i i think uh as long as
you're doing on a semi-regular basis
it's probably adequate but ultimately
yeah every hour is probably better than
than once a month um so if you can if
you can size it down and strike offers
that product then it's probably a good
uh good thing to use if you're again if
you're a long-term holder and you're not
worried necessarily about the day-to-day
fluctuations you don't need liquidity
immediately it's not something you need
to sell you're going to hold it for a
long period of time it makes a lot more
sense and what we've seen is that the
people who have done this for a long
period of time have seen tremendous
upside from a pricey price appreciation
standpoint but even the people that uh
have bought more recently within the
last year or two years when you see the
numbers of of uh buyers that are in
profit it's certainly surprising
yeah long-term holders are continuously
winning the game as you call it right
they've had the most price appreciation
because they've been in the asset the
longest so they've seen all almost all
of the price appreciation that newer
well they've seen all the price
appreciation that new investors are
seeing right so the longer you're in the
market the better is looking for a
market that's going up right if you're
in an asset that's continuously
free-falling then the longer you're the
market the worse off you are right um so
i just think long-term holders are being
benefited from being early adopters of
this and holding and holding through all
those downturns and all those bear
markets and they're reeking the benefits
of it hey you did you like this video
great we make five of them a day and
post them here on this channel make sure
you subscribe like the video and see you
next time